This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 2009, British businessman Philip Davison Sebray was celebrating his wife's 50th birthday in the Maldives when he got a phone call. The caller asked for a business meeting the next day at 8 a.m. Philip explained that that would be a little difficult, seeing as he was 4,500 miles away from work on vacation. What are you doing away at a time like this? The voice at the other end of the line shouted.
这里是隐性大脑，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2009年，英国商人菲利普·戴维森·塞布雷在马尔代夫庆祝他妻子的50岁生日时，接到了一个电话。来电者要求第二天早上8点开一个商务会议。菲利普解释说这有点困难，因为他正在距离工作地4500英里之外的地方度假。你怎么能在这种时候不在岗位上呢？电话那头的人大喊道。
Your company is in liquidation. Philip thought it was a joke in port taste. In an interview with Wales Online, he recalled at the caller assured him that it was no joking matter. Here's what happened. A British government agency had reported the demise of Phillips 134-year-old engineering company Taylor & Sons. The government agency, known as company's house, serves as a kind of registrar for British
你的公司正在清算中。菲利普以为这是一个品味低下的玩笑。在接受《威尔士在线》采访时，他回忆说来电者向他保证这不是在开玩笑。事情是这样的。一个英国政府机构报告了菲利普拥有134年历史的工程公司泰勒父子公司（Taylor & Sons）的倒闭。这个被称为公司注册局（Companies House）的政府机构，充当着英国各类
businesses. It said that Taylor & Sons, created in 1875, was being shut down. Turns out, a government clerk had made a typo. The company that was going out of business was Taylor and Sons in Manchester, not Taylor and Sons in Wales. Philip felt sick. His company had been doing well. It had some 250 employees.
企业的注册处。它宣布这家成立于1875年的泰勒父子公司正在被关闭。事实证明，是一名政府职员打错了一个字母。即将倒闭的公司是曼彻斯特的泰勒父子公司，而不是威尔士的泰勒父子公司。菲利普感到一阵恶心。他的公司一直运营良好。它大约有250名员工。
Within days, he later said in that interview with Wales Online, his contracts dried up. Orders were cancelled. Creditors demanded to be paid. The government agency did correct the mistake after some days, but a debt spiral had taken hold. In time, Taylor and Sons actually did go out of business. Not all errors are so consequential, but some are deadly, and many have unpredictable effects. Wouldn't we all prefer that governments, organizations, and companies
他在后来接受《威尔士在线》采访时表示，几天之内，他的合同就枯竭了。订单被取消了。债权人要求偿还债务。几天后，这个政府机构确实纠正了错误，但债务螺旋已经形成。最终，泰勒父子公司确实倒闭了。并非所有错误都如此严重，但有些错误是致命的，还有许多错误会产生无法预测的影响。难道我们不都希望政府、组织和公司
avoid making mistakes altogether? That's an understandable response, but it turns out that demanding no errors might be the biggest mistake of all. This week on Hidden Brain. To air is human. When people work on things mistakes are inevitable. This is true in our personal lives, in our workplaces, and at the level of public policy. Not all mistakes are created equal though. Some failures are trivial, while others can be disastrous. At Harvard Business School, Amy Edminson studies how failures come about and what we can do about them. She has surprising insights into how organizations and people should think
完全避免犯错吗？这是一个可以理解的反应，但事实证明，要求零失误可能是最大的错误。本周的隐性大脑栏目将探讨人非圣贤，孰能无过。当人们做事时，错误是不可避免的。这在我们个人的生活中、职场中以及公共政策层面上都是如此。不过，并非所有错误生来平等。有些失败是微不足道的，而另一些则可能是灾难性的。在哈佛商学院，艾米·埃德蒙森（Amy Edmondson）研究失败是如何发生的以及我们可以做些什么。她对组织和个人应该如何思考
about the mistakes they make. Amy Edminson, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Amy as a young scientist working on your first major research project, you spent months collecting data from doctors and nurses at two local hospitals. The stakes here were high. I understand that you were tracking medical mistakes. Yes, we call them adverse drug events. So that is when something bad happens to a patient that is deemed caused by human error. And so I would get a phone call from one of the physicians in the study who would say, there's just been an event. And so we're going to take a look at what happened.
他们所犯的错误有着惊人的见解。艾米·埃德蒙森，欢迎来到隐性大脑。非常感谢邀请我。艾米，作为一名年轻的科学家，你在进行你的第一个重大研究项目时，花了几个月的时间收集当地两家医院医生和护士的数据。这里的风险很高。据我了解，你在追踪医疗错误。是的，我们称之为不良药物事件。也就是当发生对病人不好的事情，并且被认为是由人为错误引起的时候。因此，研究中的一位内科医生会给我打电话说，刚刚发生了一个事件。所以我们要来看看发生了什么。
And so I would hop on my bike and ride down to the hospital and I'd find myself in a conference room and we would then sit around and hear from the perspective of different people who may have touched or been aware of the adverse event, and we try to truly understand what happened. So for instance, in one case, there was a patient that received a drug called lidocaine, and they were supposed to get a drug called heparin.
于是我会骑上自行车赶到医院，发现自己坐在一间会议室里，然后我们会坐在一起，听取可能接触过或知道该不良事件的不同人员的视角，并试图真正理解发生了什么。例如，在一个案例中，有一位患者本应使用一种名为肝素的药物，结果却被给予了一种名为利多卡因的药物。
Now the two drugs were labeled similarly, and they were in the same location even though they do very different things. Now in this case, the lidocaine would not hurt the patient, but the absence of heparin might have led to real harm. It didn't. So these adverse events didn't always involve harm, but they always involved at least the potential for harm. Now, you became aware that some teams at these hospitals were making more errors, more mistakes than others, but besides tracking mistakes, you also were examining how teams
这两种药物的标签相似，甚至放在同一个地方，尽管它们的作用完全不同。在这个案例中，利多卡因不会伤害患者，但缺少肝素可能会导致真正的伤害。事实是没有发生。因此，这些不良事件并不总是涉及伤害，但它们总是至少包含潜在的伤害。现在，你注意到这些医院里的一些团队犯的错误比其他团队更多，但除了追踪错误，你还在研究团队是如何
functioned and you found that some teams functioned better than others. Tell me about the components of teamwork that you measured? Well, I used a classic team survey called the Team Diagnostic Survey, and it measured such things as the quality of interpersonal relationships in the team, the team's own self-assessment of how well they were performing, the team's assessment of whether and the degree to which they had the resources they need to do their job well, especially interested in their assessment of the leadership of the team and how good was that leadership. And these are a set of factors that had been previously recognized
运作的，你发现有些团队比其他团队运作得更好。能跟我讲讲你所测量的团队合作的组成部分吗？嗯，我使用了一项经典的团队调查，称为团队诊断调查（Team Diagnostic Survey），它测量诸如团队中人际关系的质量、团队对自身绩效表现的自我评估、团队对其是否以及在多大程度上拥有做好工作所需的资源的评估，特别是他们对团队领导力的评估以及领导力有多好。这些是一组先前被认为
as important to team effectiveness. And you were also looking at how much people cared about their work and whether people felt like everyone was pulling their fair share of the weight. Yes, and I think that assessment is partly captured in the quality of relationships measure. But there also was the measures of their satisfaction with the work, how happy they were in their job. And all of these measures tend to travel together. So in a good team and a well-led team, they tend to be high on all of these factors and then not good team, they're low on all of these factors.
对团队效能很重要的因素。而且你还在观察人们对工作的关心程度，以及人们是否觉得每个人都分担了公平的份额？是的，我认为这个评估部分体现在关系质量的测量中。但也有对工作满意的测量，他们在工作中有多快乐。所有这些测量往往是相辅相成的。因此，在一个优秀的团队和领导良好的团队中，他们在所有这些因素上往往都很高，而在不好的团队中，他们在所有这些因素上都很低。
So you now have two sets of data, information on high performing teams, versus low performing teams, and information on teams that make few mistakes or lots of mistakes. I mean, it seems quite obvious what the answer is going to be, but what was your intuition about how the quality of teams would relate to the mistakes that teams were making? Well, my intuition was that better teamwork would lead to fewer mistakes or adverse events for patients.
所以你现在有了两套数据，关于高绩效团队与低绩效团队的信息，以及关于犯错很少或犯错很多的团队的信息。我的意思是，答案似乎显而易见，但对于团队质量与团队所犯错误之间的关系，你的直觉是什么？嗯，我的直觉是，更好的团队合作会导致更少的错误或患者不良事件。
This just makes sense, and the more I understood about the nature of patient care in a hospital, the more I realized how interdependent it was. First of all, it's 24-7 operations. So there's shift handoffs. And second of all, most patients are seen by multiple different caregivers through the course of their stay. And so the quality of the coordination and the collaboration ought to really determine the degree to which high quality care is given. So of course, I expected better teams would have fewer adverse events or mistakes. So the day comes when you're ready to analyze all of the data. You have a small computer disk with all the medication errors made by each team. Paint me a picture of what happened
这在情理之中，我对医院患者护理性质的了解越多，我就越意识到它是多么地相互依存。首先，这是24小时7天不间断的运营。所以有交接班。其次，大多数病人在住院期间都会被多位不同的护理人员诊疗。因此，协调和协作的质量应该真正决定高质量护理提供的程度。所以当然，我期望更好的团队会有更少的不良事件或错误。所以，准备好分析所有数据的那一天终于来了。你有一个小光盘，里面记录了每个团队犯的所有用药错误。请给我描绘一下那天发生的事情
that day, Amy. Well, I synced up the data on the disk with the data that I already had on the team properties in my computer and started to run the statistical analysis to connect those two data sources. And I just ran some simple correlations and I saw right away that the p-value, which indicates whether or not the finding is statistically significant,
艾米。嗯，我把光盘上的数据与我电脑中已有的团队属性数据进行了同步，并开始运行统计分析以连接这两个数据源。我运行了一些简单的相关性分析，立刻就看到p值，它指示该发现是否具有统计学意义，
I saw that the p-value indicated that my data was statistically significant. So I was very excited. And then I looked more closely, leaning into the screen, and I realized that the sign was in the wrong direction. In other words, instead of seeing a relationship between good teamwork and low error rates. The statistical significance was saying there was a relationship between good teamwork and high error rates. How could that possibly be, Amy? Well, that was my question. And I set there. I think I froze. I was upset and I was scared. And so I set there looking at it. And my first reaction was, I must have made a mistake.
我看到p值表明我的数据具有统计学意义。所以我非常兴奋。然后我凑近屏幕仔细看，我意识到符号方向反了。换句话说，没有看到良好团队合作与低错误率之间的关系。统计学意义显示的是良好团队合作与高错误率之间存在关系。怎么会这样呢，艾米？嗯，那是我的问题。我坐在那儿。我想我当时惊呆了。我很沮丧也很害怕。所以我坐在那儿看着它。我的第一反应是，我一定犯了个错误。
I must have put the data in incorrectly. So I walked very carefully through everything I'd done. I redid it. And nope, maybe my hypothesis had been a mistake, but I had not made a kind of data entry mistake. And so there it was, staring at it again, and again puzzled. It just can't be true.
我一定是把数据输入错了。所以我非常仔细地检查了我做过的一切。我重新做了一遍。没有，也许我的假设是个错误，但我没有犯那种数据输入的错误。所以它就摆在那里，再次凝视着我，我依然感到困惑。这不可能是真的。
It can't be that better teams with higher quality relationships more able and willing to collaborate effectively, to coordinate clearly could have more, not fewer, adverse drug events. And I suddenly had a thought, you know, maybe better teams don't make more mistakes. Maybe they're more able and willing to report them. And I suddenly remembered that I had inserted an extra question that wasn't in the original survey that is stated as follows.
拥有更高质量关系、更有能力和意愿进行有效协作、清晰协调的更好团队，怎么可能会有更多而不是更少的不良药物事件呢。我突然闪过一个念头，你知道，也许更好的团队不是犯了更多错误。也许他们更有能力和意愿去报告这些错误。我突然记起我在最初的调查中加了一个额外的问题，表述如下。
If you make a mistake in this unit, it's held against you, and it's rated on a seven point scale, from, you know, not at all to a great deal. And it turned out that that single item was profoundly significantly correlated with the actual error rates. So that meant that when people agreed with this item, making a mistake would not be held against you, the error rates were higher. That's not, you know, a perfect proof, but it certainly suggested that there was something in the climate of the team that would make it easier to speak up about and report
如果你在这个单位犯了错误，这会被记在你的头上，它采用七分制评分，从你知道的完全不会到很大程度上。事实证明，这单一的一项与实际错误率有着深刻的显着相关性。这意味着当人们同意这一项时，犯错不会被记在头上，错误率反而更高。这并不是，你知道的，一个完美的证明，但它确实表明团队的氛围中存在某种东西，使得人们更容易谈论和报告
error. So you hired a research assistant to actually go to the hospital and observe firsthand how teams at the hospital were functioning, testing this hypothesis that better teams in fact were more willing to report the mistakes, and that's why they were showing up as having committed greater numbers of mistakes. What did the research assistant find? Well, first of all, I think it's important to point out that I did not tell him what the survey data said, nor what the error data said.
错误。于是你雇了一个研究助理去医院实地观察医院团队的运作方式，来检验这个假设，即更好的团队实际上更愿意报告错误，这就是为什么他们表现出犯了更多错误的原因。研究助理发现了什么？嗯，首先，我认为指出这一点很重要，我没有告诉他调查数据是什么，也没有告诉他错误数据是什么。
He only knew that there was a study of error going on. And I said, I just want your impression of what it's like to work in these units. I want you to observe them. I want you to observe them. I want you to interview them when they're on breaks and just learn as much as you can about these different work environments. Off he went. After a week or so, he came back. He said, they really are very different places to work.
他只知道正在进行一项关于错误的研究。我说，我只想要你对在这些单位工作是什么感觉的印象。我想让你观察他们。我想让你观察他们。我想让你在他们休息时采访他们，并尽可能多地了解这些不同的工作环境。他出发了。大约一周后，他回来了。他说，它们确实是非常不同的工作场所。
Some of them, he said, his words were just far more open. And others, he said, again, his words were authoritarian in nature. In some units, people would say things like, if you make a mistake in this unit, you get treated like a two-year-old, or you get put on trial. So, you really don't want to have made one. Or the nurse manager who is essentially the boss of the unit, if you're a nurse, would get angry and treat you badly. In other units, even though they're only maybe across the hall or up a floor or two, he found people saying things like, well, in this unit, it's really easy to talk about mistakes
他说，有些地方，用他的话说，要开放得多。而其他的，他再次用他的话说，本质上是专制的。在一些单位，人们会说这样的话：如果你在这个单位犯了错误，你会被当作两岁小孩对待，或者你会被送上审判。所以，你真的不想犯错。或者作为单位老板的护士长，如果你是护士，会生气并对你不好。而在其他单位，尽管它们可能只隔着大厅或相隔一两层楼，他发现人们说这样的话，嗯，在这个单位，谈论错误真的很容易
because of what's at stake. Patients' health is at stake. So of course, you're never afraid to speak up and you're never afraid to tell the nurse manager about what you see. I'm wondering how this insights started to change your thinking about the nature of mistakes in failure, Amy. Well, to begin with, I realized you can't learn from mistakes
因为事关重大。患者的健康处于危险之中。所以当然，你从不害怕开口，也从不害怕把你的所见所闻告诉护士长。我想知道这种见解是如何开始改变你对艾米失败性质的看法。嗯，首先，我意识到你无法向未报告的错误学习
that aren't reported. When we think about organizations and teams and the goal of learning from mistakes and learning from failures, job one is to make sure we're actually talking about them honestly and openly. And so that started me thinking that maybe there are differences in work environments in what I called then interpersonal climate.
当我们在考虑组织和团队以及从错误中学习、从失败中学习的目标时，首要任务是确保我们真诚、公开地讨论它们。这让我开始思考，工作环境可能存在差异，也就是我当时所说的人际氛围。
And if the interpersonal climate differs, that would have real implications for people's ability to learn from mistakes and failures. Amy was starting to see that errors and failure are not always signals or disaster and dysfunction. When we come back, why failures are not created equal, how to tell them apart and what we should do about different kinds of failure. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When airline pilots make grave mistakes, planes crash and people can die. When surgeons make mistakes, patients can bleed out on the operating table or have the
如果人际氛围不同，这将对人们从错误和失败中学习的能力产生真正的影响。艾米开始认识到，错误和失败并不总是灾难和功能失调的信号。稍后回来，为什么失败不尽相同，如何区分它们以及我们应该如何处理不同类型的失败。您正在收听的是隐性大脑，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是隐性大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当航空飞行员犯下严重错误时，飞机坠毁，人们可能会丧生。当外科医生犯错时，患者可能会在手术台上流血过多或被切除
wrong limb amputated. When you leave something in the oven too long, no one dies, but you will have to eat burnt cinders for dinner. There is a reason parents, teachers, managers and chefs try so hard to stamp out errors. Mistakes are costly, unpleasant and dangerous. At Harvard Business School, Amy Edmondson studies the science of mistakes. She's discovered that we make a big mistake when we lump all failures into the same bucket. Amy if you told the average leader of a company that you could completely eliminate all mistakes
错误的肢体。当你把东西在烤箱里放得太久时，没有人会死，但你晚餐只能吃烧焦的炭渣了。这就是父母、老师、经理和厨师如此努力消除错误的原因。错误代价高昂、令人不快且危险。在哈佛商学院，艾米·埃德蒙森研究错误的科学。她发现，当我们把所有失败归为一类时，我们就犯了一个大错误。艾米，如果你告诉一家公司的普通高管，你可以完全消除她公司的所有错误
at her company, she would probably be ecstatic. But you say that we're making a mistake in the way we think about mistakes. Why is it problematic to try to completely eliminate all failure? You said it at the outset to errors human. We are fallible human beings and we will always make mistakes. I don't mean we'll make mistakes all the time, but there is always the possibility that a mistake will occur. So a better approach is to think about how can we be set up to catch incorrect mistakes before they cause harm. And in some ways from the hospital study that you were mentioning to me earlier, when you
她可能会欣喜若狂。但你说我们在对错误的思考方式上犯了错误。试图完全消除所有失败有什么问题？你从一开始就说过人非圣贤，孰能无过。我们是会犯错的人类，我们总是会犯错。我的意思不是我们随时随地都在犯错误，而是总有发生错误的可能。所以更好的方法是考虑我们如何才能建立机制，在错误造成伤害之前抓住不正确的错误。某种程度上，从你刚才提到的医院研究中，当你
send a signal that failure is not going to be tolerated, what happens then is not that the failure stop, but that the failure stop being reported. Exactly. It's one of these profound insights that I think way too few leaders or even just people in families recognize that when you insist that we must have, you know, error-free performance or error-free lives. The main thing that happens is not that error goes away, it's that you stop hearing about it.
发出不容忍失败的信号时，接下来的情况并非失败停止了，而是失败不再被报告了。完全正确。这是深刻的见解之一，我认为太少的领导者甚至家庭中的普通人都没有意识到，当你坚持我们必须拥有，你知道的，零失误的表现或零失误的生活时。发生的主要事情不是错误消失了，而是你不再听到有关它的消息了。
There's another approach to failure. In some ways, this is the polar opposite to the first approach. And this idea is popular, or at least used to be very popular, among tech entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley. And this was to celebrate failure. Fail fast, fail early was the model. Was this a better approach than leaders telling employees that failure was unacceptable? I don't think it's possible to say one is better than the other.
对待失败还有另一种方法。从某些方面来看，这与第一种方法截然相反。这种观点在硅谷的技术创业者中很受欢迎，或者说过去曾经非常受欢迎。那就是庆祝失败。模式就是快速失败，趁早失败。与告诉员工失败是不可接受的领导相比，这是一种更好的方法吗？我认为不可能说哪一种比另一种更好。
They are better for different contexts. So the fail fast fail often is a fantastic approach for a laboratory or for an R&D group. The, you know, let's adhere to the highest possible standards and try our very best to get everything right is how we want to run an operating theater. Right. If you're running an airline company, I'm not sure you want to tell your pilots,
它们在不同的情境下各有优势。因此，快速失败、经常失败对于实验室或研发团队来说是一个绝佳的方法。而你知道的，我们要恪守最高标准，尽最大努力把每件事都做好，这正是我们想要在手术室里推行的运作方式。没错。如果你在经营一家航空公司，我可不确定你是否会告诉你的飞行员，
fail fast fail often. Of course not. Imagine being the head of a factory making Toyota automobiles who decides, let's fail fast today. No, no, no, no. So, rather than a blanket rejection of failure or a blanket embrace of failure, you say that we need to stop treating all mistakes as if they are the same. And you cite the social scientist, Sim Sittkin, who once made the case for something he called
快速失败，经常失败。当然不会。想象一下，如果一个丰田汽车工厂的负责人决定说，我们今天就来个快速失败吧。不，不，不，不。因此，与其一概拒绝失败或是一概拥抱失败，你提出我们需要停止将所有错误混为一谈。你引用了社会学家西姆·西特金（Sim Sittkin）的观点，他曾为某种被称为
intelligent failures. What are intelligent failures, Amy? Intelligent failures are the undesired results of forays into new territory that are driven by a hypothesis and are as small as possible. And so, in a sense, an intelligent failure is an experiment that didn't produce the result you had truly wanted it to produce. In some ways, what that implies then is that intelligent failures are almost always failures that take place on the frontiers of knowledge or discovery. Yes, so there's two kinds of frontiers. One is the frontier of knowledge or discovery
智能失败的事物进行过辩护。什么是智能失败，艾米？智能失败是对未知领域的探索所产生的非预期结果，这些探索是由假设驱动的并且规模尽可能小。从某种意义上说，智能失败就是一个没有产生你真正期望结果的实验。在某种程度上，这意味着智能失败几乎总是发生在知识或发现的前沿领域的失败。是的，所以这里有两种前沿。一种是知识或发现的前沿，
in that we're talking about a place where no one has been before. And the other is the frontier. It's just new for you. Let's say you pick up a new hobby, you decide to take a ceramics class. That's new territory for you and you can expect some intelligent failures along the way, even if it's not new to the world. I want to come back and talk at greater length about intelligent failure. Later in our conversation, you have a series of very useful insights into how people and organizations can use intelligent failure as an engine for growth and discovery. But it may be helpful before we do that to be able to spot two other kinds of failure.
也就是说我们正在讨论一个前人未曾涉足的地方。另一种前沿则是，它对你来说是崭新的。比方说你培养了一个新爱好，决定去上陶艺课。对你而言这就是全新领域，在这个过程中你可能会遇到一些智能失败，即使这在世界上并非新鲜事。我想回过头来更深入地探讨智能失败。在我们之后的对话中，你对个人和组织如何利用智能失败作为增长和发现的引擎提出了一系列非常有价值的见解。但在我们这样做之前，能够识别出另外两种失败可能会很有帮助。
These are the kinds of failure we should in fact do our best to stamp out. Now the first can superficially look like intelligent failure because these failures can also take place while people are engaged in complex tasks on the frontiers of human knowledge and discovery. In 2003, the Space Shuttle Columbia broke apart upon reentry into its atmosphere, killing the Seven Astronauts aboard. You conducted an in-depth analysis of what happened to the Columbia when it broke apart. It was something that you ended up calling a complex failure. Tell me the story of what happened to me. Well, the shuttle had completely combusted on reentry into the Earth's atmosphere on February 1, 2003.
这些其实是我们应该尽最大努力消除的失败。第一种表面上看起来很像智能失败，因为当人们在人类知识和发现的前沿从事复杂任务时，也可能会发生这种失败。2003年，哥伦比亚号航天飞机在重返大气层时解体，机上七名宇航员不幸遇难。你对哥伦比亚号解体的原因进行了深入分析。你最终将这种情况称为复杂失败。请跟我讲讲当时发生了什么。好的，这艘航天飞机在2003年2月1日重返地球大气层时完全烧毁了。
It was later determined that the reason for that is something called a foam strike. Now what happens is to get the shuttle out beyond the Earth's atmosphere, it takes off with the help of a solid rocket booster. And that has the energy to bring it out into space. And that is surrounded by insulating foam. And occasionally, little bits of that insulating foam would break off just because of the pressure of the launch. And sometimes those little bits strike the shuttle and make little dents, you know, just little
后来确定原因是一种被称为泡沫撞击的现象。事情是这样的，为了把航天飞机送出地球大气层，它需要在固体火箭助推器的帮助下起飞。这种助推器拥有将其送入太空的能量。它周围包裹着隔热泡沫。偶尔，由于发射时的压力，一小块一小块的隔热泡沫会脱落。有时这些小块会撞击航天飞机并留下小凹痕，你知道的，这只是一些
nuisance problems that would lead to maintenance later on to fix them up. But in this case, there was a rather large piece of foam that dislodged and hit the shuttle on a delicate spot, the leading edge of the wing. And so it unfortunately made a larger hole, a hole the size of a human head. Now the hole that size in the shuttle, as it re-entered the Earth's atmosphere, allowed all the hot gases of the atmosphere in and led to instant combustion. Now, tell me a little bit about what happened in the days leading up to the launch, because at least in retrospect when people went back and did the investigation, they tried to follow
会留到以后进行维修解决的小麻烦。但在这次事件中，一块相当大的泡沫脱落了，并撞击了航天飞机脆弱的部位——机翼前缘。不幸的是，它撞出一个更大的洞，一个有成年人脑袋那么大的洞。航天飞机上有这么大一个洞，当它重返地球大气层时，就会让大气层中所有的高温气体进入，从而导致瞬间燃烧。现在，请跟我讲讲发射前几天发生的事情，因为至少在事后人们回过头去进行调查时，他们试图顺着
the breadcrumbs and ask, could we have known what was going to happen before it actually happened? what was going to happen before it actually happened. Well, yes, and in this case, unlike the even more famous challenger incident, no one had any worries leading up to the launch, which was January 16, 2003. But on January 17, the day after the launch, an engineer named Rodney Rocco was looking at the launch video, and he saw just a grainy spec on the screen that bothered him. Because he thought that grainy spec might be a foam strike, and the very fact that it couldn't really make out what it was, but the very fact that he could see a spec at all suggested to him that the chunk, if it were a
蛛丝马迹去追问，在事情真正发生之前，我们本可以知道会发生什么吗？在事情真正发生之前，我们本可以知道会发生什么吗？嗯，是的，在这个案例中，与更著名的挑战者号事故不同，在2003年1月16日发射前的日子里，没有人有任何担忧。但在1月17日，即发射的第二天，一位名叫罗德尼·罗科（Rodney Rocco）的工程师在查看发射视频时，看到屏幕上有一个模糊的点让他感到不安。因为他认为那个模糊的点可能是一次泡沫撞击，而且事实上他无法真正辨认出那是什么，但能看到一个光点的这一事实向他表明，如果这是一次
foam strike, it might be big enough to do real damage rather than just create a nuisance and a maintenance problem. And so that worried him. Now, that was about 15 days before reentry. So theoretically, NASA had 15 days to kind of figure out whether there had been a real problem and if so, whether there was an alternate plan to the simple reentry that was part of the schedule. In other words, could they find out A, is there really a problem and then B, if so, is there anything we could do about it in that 15-day window?
泡沫撞击，它可能大到足以造成真正的破坏，而不仅仅是制造麻烦和维修问题。这让他很担心。当时距离重返大气层大约还有15天。因此理论上，美国宇航局有15天的时间来弄清楚这是否是一个真正的问题，如果是的话，是否有替代方案来取代计划中的简单重返大气层。换句话说，他们能否查明A，这到底是不是一个问题，然后B，如果是的话，在这个15天的窗口期内我们能做些什么？
But unfortunately, Roka and his immediate colleagues were never able to get senior managers at NASA to take the problem seriously, to really believe that there was a problem. Was this partly because there had been other foam strikes that turned out to be fairly minimal routine maintenance kinds of issues? Exactly. So unfortunately, people at NASA had learned to equate the foam strikes that did happen with just maintenance. They're not a safety risk, but they had had so many of these little tiny foam strikes that they didn't think it was worth looking into. And in some ways this is sort of understandable, even though in retrospect we know this was a mistake,
但不幸的是，罗科和他身边的同事从来没能让美国宇航局的高级管理层认真对待这个问题，也没有让他们真正相信这是一个问题。这部分是因为以前也发生过其他泡沫撞击，结果证明都是些微不足道的常规维护问题吗？完全正确。不幸的是，美国宇航局的人已经习惯于将发生的泡沫撞击与日常维护等同起来。它们不是安全风险，但他们经历过太多次这种微小的泡沫撞击，以至于认为不值得去调查。从某些方面来看这其实是可以理解的，尽管事后我们知道这是一个错误，
I mean, if your shuttles have been returning safely despite these form strikes, it's quite understandable how people could have become plazate to them. It's completely understandable. Their own experience had taught them that it was fine. I have enormous empathy for everyone who was a part of that shuttle program, who believed it to be fine. Because I'm that way too.
我的意思是，如果你们的航天飞机尽管有这些泡沫撞击却一直安全返回，人们对它们习以为常也是完全可以理解的。这完全可以理解。他们自身的经验告诉他们一切正常。我对参与那个航天飞机项目并相信一切正常的每个人都抱有极大的同情。因为我也是那样的人。
I'm a fallible human being who overly trusts my prior experience and often fails to be curious enough about, well, maybe this one's different. Ooh, let me look into it. Let me see what I can learn. So it's tragic, but there are no bad guys here. You point out that complex failures are often not the result of one big cause, but rather a number of small factors that line up perfectly in this perfect storm, as you called it. I understand that in the healthcare arena, these kind of complex failures are
我是一个容易犯错的人，过度相信我先前的经验，并且往往缺乏足够的好奇心去探究“嗯，也许这次不一样呢？哦，让我去查查。让我看看能学到什么”。所以这很悲剧，但这里没有坏人。你指出，复杂失败往往不是由一个重大原因造成的，而是由许多小因素在完美风暴中完美交织在一起造成的，正如你所说的那样。据我所知，在医疗保健领域，这种复杂的失败有时被
sometimes called the Swiss cheese model of failure. Explain that term for me, Amy, and explain how you use this analogy to analyze a case in which a young patient received a dangerous overdose of morphine. That's right. And the Swiss cheese metaphor comes from an erythearist named James Reason from the UK. And he uses this metaphor of Swiss cheese to try to explain the notion of complex failures. He says, you know, when your cheese has air bubbles in it, those are in a sense defects in the cheese, but they're not problematic until they line up and make a tunnel. Just rarely happens, but when it happens, then the error goes all the way through.
称为失败的瑞士奶酪模型。艾米，请为我解释一下这个术语，并说明你如何用这个类比来分析一个年轻患者接受了危险剂量的吗啡的案例。好的。瑞士奶酪隐喻来自英国的一位错误理论家詹姆斯·雷森（James Reason）。他用瑞士奶酪这个隐喻来试图解释复杂失败的概念。他说，你知道的，当你的奶酪里有气泡时，从某种意义上说，这些就是奶酪中的缺陷，但它们不会构成问题，直到它们排成一条直线并形成一条通道。这种情况很少发生，但一旦发生，错误就会贯穿始终。
So in the case of this morphine overdose, I was able to analyze seven factors contributing to the accident. So to begin with, there had been an overflow in the intensive care unit where most post-surgical patients go, and this boy had just had surgery. So he was sent to the regular medical floor, which has less specialized staff. So that's one factor.
所以在这次吗啡过量事件中，我能够分析出导致这起事故的七个因素。首先，重症监护室出现了床位饱和，大多数术后患者都会去那里，而这个男孩刚刚做完手术。因此他被送到了普通病房，那里的专业医护人员较少。所以这是一个因素。
Now, that by itself would not lead to this kind of overdose. But unfortunately, there was a brand new nurse right out of school who was assigned to take care of him. And then there was an infusion pump that's used to deliver this pain medication. And it happened to be located in a rather dark corner, making it a little harder to see. And the nurse was also hadn't done this kind of programming before, so we asked for a colleague to help.
单凭这一点并不会导致这种过量。但不幸的是，刚毕业的一名全新护士被指派照顾他。然后是一个用于输送这种止痛药的输液泵。它碰巧位于一个比较昏暗的角落里，让人有点难以看清。而且这名护士以前也没有做过这种编程，所以她请求同事帮忙。
She stopped by to help, but she didn't do her calculations independently. She just looked over his shoulder and verified his. And then finally, the medication label was printed badly by IT and a little difficult to read. So that contributed to them not able to determine the concentration of the drug, exactly right. And so all of those holes in this Swiss cheese lined up and let this overdose go through. Fortunately, it was noticed very quickly and they called the physician and instantly delivered a drug to help correct the error. But it's the kind of story that is unfortunately common in healthcare, but especially in any complex system.
她顺道过来帮忙，但她并没有独立进行计算。她只是站在他身后看了一眼并核实了他的计算结果。最后，药物标签被IT部门打印得很糟糕，有点难以辨认。这就导致他们无法准确确定药物浓度。于是，瑞士奶酪上的所有这些漏洞排成了一条线，让这次过量事故发生了。幸运的是，人们很快就发现了这一点，他们叫来了医生并立即注射了解毒药物以纠正错误。但这个故事在医疗保健领域，特别是在任何复杂的系统中都不幸地很常见。
And in some ways they made it, it points out to me the importance of allowing people to speak up about problems that they're seeing and also to take a systemic view of problems rather than looking for the smoking gun approach to problems. It's absolutely right and our tendency is to look for that smoking gun. Our brains are used to looking for the single cause, the small part that broke rather than to back up and see how the parts are relating to each other and coming together in a way that created the failure or created the flaw. And it's a discipline to sort of realize that there's multiple factors
从某种意义上说，它向我指出了让人们大声说出他们所看到的问题的重要性，同时也指出了对问题采取系统性看法的必要性，而不是在问题中寻找“一枪毙命”的归因方法。完全正确，我们的倾向就是去寻找那个“一枪毙命”的罪魁祸首。我们的大脑习惯于寻找单一原因、寻找那个损坏的小零件，而不是退后一步去看看各个部分是如何相互关联并组合在一起从而导致失败或产生缺陷的。意识到存在多种因素需要一种克制力，
and in order to prevent complex failures, speaking up is essential. People need to know that their voices are welcome, because all you have to do is catch and correct one of the many factors, and you've prevented the failure. It is possible to implement procedures that ensure that errors are caught and corrected early. Tell me how this is done by the Carmaker Toyota. Toyota is one of the best examples of doing this well and probably the best practice that
为了防止复杂失败，大声说出来是至关重要的。人们需要知道他们的意见是受欢迎的，因为你只需要发现并纠正众多因素中的一个，就能防止失败的发生。完全有可能实施确保及早发现并纠正错误的程序。请告诉我汽车制造商丰田是如何做到这一点的。丰田是这方面做得最好的典范之一，而且可能最好的实践，
is maybe even the most famous of the Toyota production system is something called the Andon cord. And that is a literal cord that any team member is encouraged to pull whenever they see something wrong, or even more importantly, whenever they see something that might be wrong. Now many people think once you pull the cord, the line instantly stops. It doesn't. When you pull the cord, what happens is that a team leader comes quickly over and says, what do you see? And you explain. And the two of you together diagnose what's happening. And most of the time, it turns out that you can either fix it or recognize that there wasn't a real problem and the line keeps going. But one out of 12 times, there is a real problem there. The line will stop and it won't start again until that problem is fixed. So that
甚至也是丰田生产方式中最著名的，就是所谓的安灯拉绳。这是一个实际的绳子，鼓励任何团队成员在看到问题时，或者更重要的是，在看到可能存在问题时去拉动它。很多人认为一旦你拉了绳子，生产线就会立即停止。其实并非如此。当你拉动绳子时，发生的情况是团队领导会迅速走过来问：“你看到了什么？”然后你进行解释。你们两个一起诊断发生了什么。大多数时候，你会发现要么你能修复它，要么意识到并没有真正的问题，生产线继续运行。但十二分之一的情况下，确实存在真实的问题。生产线会停止，并且在问题解决之前不会重新启动。所以这就
prevents the complex failure of some small problem moving on downstream and we're pouring good money after bad at that point. Because when you stop the assembly line, when you're stopping production, it is costly. But I guess in the long run, the benefit is that the production becomes a higher quality production, and over time, you're starting to stamp out more and more mistakes. Exactly. So, yes, it's absolutely costly in the short term. If the line stops for a minute, that is literally the loss of one car sale. So you are allowing a frontline associate to cost the company several thousand dollars any time they wish. And of course, as your question
防止了某个小问题向后道工序蔓延从而导致复杂失败，在那时我们就会为了弥补损失而花更多的冤枉钱。因为当你停下装配线，当你停止生产时，成本是很高的。但我想从长远来看，好处是生产质量变得更高了，随着时间的推移，你开始消除越来越多的错误。完全正确。所以，是的，短期内成本绝对是高昂的。如果生产线停止一分钟，那就意味着直接损失了一辆车的销售。因此，你允许一线员工在他们希望的任何时候让公司损失数千美元。当然，正如你的问题
suggested, they understand that this is money well spent. This is not a cost. This is an investment because every time we can stamp out small problems along the way, we are less at risk for producing anything less than a perfect car with high quality that will serve that customer well for years and years. We've talked about intelligent failures and complex failures. In some ways at the bottom of your taxonomy of failures are what you call basic failures. You encountered one of these failures when you went sailing a few years ago. Tell me what happened, Amy. Well, I had signed up for an alumni regatta at Harvard. And when I got there, I realized kind of to my horror that everybody else there
所暗示的，他们明白这钱花得很值。这不是成本。这是一项投资，因为每次我们都能在过程中消除小问题，我们就越少面临生产出任何不够完美的、高品质汽车的风险，从而能够经年累月地很好地服务客户。我们讨论了智能失败和复杂失败。在某种程度上，在你对失败的分类体系的最底层，是被称为基本失败的东西。几年前你去航海时就遭遇了其中一次失败。艾米，告诉我发生了什么。嗯，我报名参加了哈佛大学的一个校友帆船赛。当我到达那里时，我有点惊恐地意识到那里的其他人
was about two years out of school, not several decades as I was. But that was okay. I can do it. I'm a good sailor, right? You know, I'll do the best I can. So off I went and I was thrilled to not come in dead last in the first race. After the second race, there was a break. Where all the boats go back to the dock before the regatta continues. The dock was dead downwind, which means that if you're in a sailboat, the boom on the sailboat holding up the sail is as far out as it can possibly go. And if you're dead downwind and the wind shifts even just a little bit, the boom is at risk of flying over to the other side.
都是毕业大约两年的年轻人，而不是像我这样毕业几十年的人。但没关系。我能行。我是一个好的水手，对吧？你知道的，我会尽力而做好。于是我就出发了，很高兴在第一场比赛中没有垫底。第二场比赛结束后有一个中场休息。所有船只都要在帆船赛继续之前返回码头。码头正好处于顺风方向，这意味着如果你在帆船上，帆船上支撑着帆的横桁会尽可能地向外伸展。如果你正处于顺风方向，而风向哪怕稍微改变了一点，横桁都有可能飞到另一侧。
So any experienced sailor and I am an experienced sailor knows that. So we all know that when you're heading dead downwind, you had better be vigilant because you are at risk. Now in the Charles River where this regatta was, the wind is notoriously shifty. But the race was over, we're just heading into the shore, so I'm chatting with my crew, a little bit relaxed, and all of a sudden the boom flies across the boat with a little wind shift, knocks me out. Next thing, you know, I'm in the freezing cold Charles River. Oh god, you know, I'm in a freezing cold, Charles River. Oh, God, you're not got knocked overboard.
所以任何有经验的水手——而我就是一个有经验的水手——都知道这一点。因此我们都知道，当你径直顺风航行时，你最好保持警惕，因为你处于危险之中。现在，在举行这次帆船赛的查尔斯河上，风向是出了名的变幻莫测。但比赛已经结束了，我们正驶向岸边，所以我正和船员闲聊，稍微放松了一下，突然之间随着风向的一点变化，横桁猛地横扫过船身，把我撞了出去。接下来的事情，你知道的，我就掉进了冰冷的查尔斯河里。哦天哪，你知道的，我掉进了一个冰冷的查尔斯河里。哦，天哪，你被撞落水了。
I got knocked overboard. It's some early May, the water is probably 40 degrees. Fortunately, my crew was a fantastic sailor. You know, quickly turns the boat around to come get me. I climb in the back, the stern of the boat, and then I just see it, all the blood everywhere in the hull that's coming out of my head. So, I've led to nine stitches in the side of my head, and it was a basic failure.
我被撞落水了。那是五月初，水温大概只有40华氏度。幸运的是，我的船员是个出色的水手。你知道的，迅速把船调头来接我。我爬到船尾，然后我看到了，船舱里到处都是血，从我头上流出来。所以，我头上缝了九针，这是一次基本失败。
It was a small moment of inattention, looking away, not paying attention, just being overly casual when, in a sense, I'm operating dangerous machinery. And in some ways, I think what I hear you say is that the situations in which we tell ourselves, you know, I can do this in my sleep. These are the situations in which basic failures can often happen. That's exactly right. Anytime you hear yourself or someone else saying, oh, I can do this in my sleep, watch out.
那是一个短暂的分心时刻，视线移开，没有集中注意力，仅仅是因为过于随意，而从某种意义上说，我当时正在操作危险的机械。从某种程度上说，我想我听到你所说的是，当我们对自己说“你知道的，我闭着眼睛都能做这个”时，这种情境正是经常发生基本失败的情境。完全正确。每当你听到自己或其他人说“哦，我闭着眼睛都能做这个”时，就要小心了。
You can't. I understand that a simple tool like a checklist can be very effective when it comes to preventing basic errors. We've actually talked about the power of checklist on an earlier episode of Hidden Brain. You've pointed out Amy that sort of just having a checklist is not enough. You actually have to do it mindfully. And you described the story of an airline crash that took place some years ago. Tell me the story of what happened. So it was a freezing cold January morning in Washington DC, and Air Florida flight 90 was headed for Fort Lauderdale, back home, I guess. And unfortunately, they crashed into the Potomac River. Why did that happen? Well, it turns out, yes, they use the checklist.
你做不到。我理解，当涉及到预防基本错误时，像检查表这样简单的工具可以非常有效。我们实际上在之前的一期《隐藏的大脑》节目中讨论过检查表的威力。艾米，你指出仅仅拥有一张检查表是不够的。你实际上必须用心去执行它。你描述了几年前发生的一起飞机失事的故事。请讲讲当时发生了什么。那是华盛顿特区一个寒冷的冬日早晨，佛罗里达航空90号航班正飞往劳德代尔堡，我想是回老家。不幸的是，他们坠入了波托马克河。为什么会这样？嗯，事实证明，是的，他们使用了检查表。
And most of our listeners are probably aware that the checklist includes the item anti-ice. When the first officer said as part of the checklist, anti-ice, the captain said habitually off. It's Air Florida. I think most of their flights would not be using the anti-ice machinery. The first officer went on to the next item on the checklist. That was a tiny but crucial and catastrophic mistake that led to this terrible failure. Because in fact, you did want to deice the wings before taking off on that very cold day in Washington DC. That's exactly right. You wanted to deice the wings and take the time that is required to do that to have a safe takeoff. Amy's work on how to generate fewer basic and complex failures makes sense.
大多数听众可能都知道，检查清单中包含一项是“防冰”。当副驾驶在念到检查清单中的“防冰”时，机长习惯性地回答了“关闭”。那是佛罗里达航空，我想他们的大多数航班都不会使用防冰设备。副驾驶接着念了检查清单上的下一项。这是一个虽小但至关重要且灾难性的错误，导致了这场可怕的事故。因为事实上，在华盛顿特区那个非常寒冷的的日子起飞前，你确实需要给机翼除冰。完全正确。你想要给机翼除冰，并花上必要的时间来做到这一点，以确保安全起飞。埃米关于如何减少基础和复杂失败的研究很有意义。
We all want to see fewer errors in hospitals and in space shuttle missions. When we come back, in a world where failure is generally stigmatized, how to get people and organizations to do the hard thing, systematically identify places where they can fail intelligently. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Amy Edmondson studies the science of
我们都希望看到医院和航天飞机任务中的错误更少。当我们回来时，在一个普遍将失败污名化的世界里，如何让人和组织去做那件困难的事，系统性地识别出他们可以进行明智失败的地方。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。埃米·埃德蒙森研究的是
failure. She's the author of right kind of wrong, the science of failing well. In her research, she has found that we make a mistake when we lump all mistakes into the same bucket. There are indeed many kinds of failure that we should actively try to stamp out, but taking an axe to all mistakes ignores the fact that some failures are actually useful. They are what Amy and her colleagues call intelligent failures. Amy, you found that intelligent failures happen in very specific circumstances. The first is that the failure happens in new and uncharted territory. I understand that you spoke to a prominent chemist, Jennifer Heemsstra,
失败的科学。她是《正确的失败：善于失败的科学》一书的作者。在她的研究中，她发现当我们把所有错误混为一谈时，我们就犯了错误。确实有很多种失败是我们应该积极努力消除的，但对所有错误一刀切，忽视了一个事实，即有些失败其实是有用的。它们就是埃米和她的同事所称的“明智的失败”。埃米，你发现明智的失败发生在非常特定的情况下。首先是失败发生在新的、未知的领域。据我了解，你采访了一位杰出的化学家詹妮弗·海姆斯特拉，
and like many scientists, she does work on the frontiers of knowledge. I mean, she's trying to discover things that we don't know already. What did she tell you about what failure looks like in her lab? Well, she has a wonderful way of leading her very thriving laboratory. She tells her students and young scientists, we're going to fail all day. And she says failure is a part of science. And of course, she's right. And what she means is, if we are on the leading edge of our field, and that's where we hope to be, we're going to have some very smart, well-informed hypotheses, but many, if not most of them, in fact in her view, 90% of them will end in failure. They will have been wrong. But each of those failures is in itself an important discovery.
就像许多科学家一样，她的工作处于知识的前沿。我的意思是，她试图发现我们尚不知道的事物。关于在她实验室里失败是什么样子的，她对你说了什么？嗯，她有一种绝佳的方式来领导她那个非常繁荣的实验室。她告诉她的学生和年轻科学家：“我们整天都会失败。”她说失败是科学的一部分。当然，她是正确的。她的意思是，如果我们处于我们领域的尖端，而那正是我们希望身处的地方，我们将会有一些非常聪明、见解深刻的假设，但其中的许多假设，如果不是大多数的话——事实上在她看来，其中90%的假设——最终都会以失败告终。它们将被证明是错误的。但每一次这样的失败本身都是一个重大的发现。
It lets them know what didn't work so that they can then quickly rethink and try the next one and hope that that might work. In some ways, it's like wandering around in a dark room with your arms outstretched and you're searching for the door, and each stab in the dark might not give you the door handle, but it tells you where the door handle is not. And eventually, if you make a sufficient number of failures, you're likely to eventually find the door handle. I think that's a wonderful image.
它让他们知道什么行不通，这样他们就能迅速重新思考并尝试下一个，并希望那个可能会奏效。在某些方面，这就像在一个黑暗的房间里四处走动，伸出双臂寻找门，每一次在黑暗中的摸索可能都找不到门把手，但它告诉你门把手不在哪里。最终，如果你进行了足够多的失败，你很可能会最终找到门把手。我认为这是一个绝佳的比喻。
And you can take that image into so many different aspects of your life, whether that's finding a life partner or innovating in how you do your work or in the kitchen, trying a new dish. And eventually you'll find that door handle. You see that blind dates are examples of intelligent failure because such failures are inherently unpredictable. What do you mean by this?
你可以把这个比喻应用到你生活的许多不同方面，无论是寻找生活伴侣、在工作方式上进行创新，还是在厨房里尝试一新菜肴。最终你会找到那个门把手。你看，相亲就是明智失败的例子，因为这种失败本质上是不可预测的。你这话是什么意思？
If you are looking for a partner, particularly, let's say, a blind date, whether from a mutual friend or an app, you go out and you're going to meet someone for the first time. There's no real way to know for sure in advance whether this is going to be thumbs up or thumbs down. There is an opportunity here. You hope to meet someone and get along with them. You've done as much as you can to figure out whether this is a viable possibility. And so off you go, and if it's a failure, it's an intelligent failure. I understand that you know a couple of people in your own family who corded this kind of failure.
如果你在寻找伴侣，特别是，比方说相亲，无论是通过共同的朋友还是通过应用程序，你出去和某人进行第一次见面。事先实在没有办法确切知道这会是得到赞许还是遭到拒绝。这里有一个机会。你希望能遇到某人并和他们合得来。你已经尽你所能去弄清楚这是否是一种切实可行的可能性。所以你就出发了，如果这是一次失败，那它就是一次明智的失败。据我了解，你家族里有几个人曾追求过这种失败。
Tell me the story of your mom Mary and her friend Bill. Well, so my mother grew up in New York City in the same neighborhood as a boy named Bill. They were good friends. And they just stayed in touch, even after they went off to college. My mother went to an all-women's college called Vassar. Bill was then an all-male college called Princeton, and he had a friend and named Frank. And he said, Bill thought it would be fun for my mother to come down
给我讲讲你母亲玛丽和她的朋友比尔的故事。好的，我母亲在纽约市长大，和一个名叫比尔的男孩住在同一个社区。他们是好朋友。即使在他们上大学之后，他们也一直保持着联系。我母亲去了一所全女子大学叫瓦萨学院。比尔当时去了一所全男子大学叫普林斯顿，他有一个朋友叫弗兰克。他说，比尔认为我母亲能下来会很有趣，
on one of these weekends that were organized with dances and so forth. And he said, you know, Mary, why don't you come, I think you'll like this guy. So my mother came and spent the whole weekend at Princeton and she had a terrible time. She didn't like him one bit. He drank too much. He was too forward. She wished she had stayed home at Vassar doing her homework. So it was a failure. It might not doing her homework. So it was a failure.
在那些组织了舞会等等的周末里。他说：“你知道的，玛丽，你为什么不来呢，我想你会喜欢这个家伙的。”所以我母亲去了，在普林斯顿度过了整个周末，她过得很糟糕。她一点也不喜欢他。他喝了太多酒。他太轻浮了。她真希望自己留在瓦萨学院做家庭作业。所以这是一次失败。可能不是不做家庭作业。所以这是一次失败。
It might not have been intelligent, but it was a failure. Then, Fass forward a year or so and Bill says, I have a friend I want you to meet and she's thinking, no way. And he says, no, really, I really think you're going to like this guy. He's the brother of a woman I'm dating and I really, really want you to meet him. And my mother probably intuiting the strategy of small losses, agreed to meet this other guy for a drink, right? Not a weekend away, but a drink and loan behold, this new guy named Bob and Mary hit it off right away, really liked each other, had a great deal in common and they ultimately married and those are my parents.
这可能谈不上明智，但它是一次失败。然后，时间快进了一年左右，比尔说：“我有一个朋友想让你见见。”而她心想：没门。他说：“不，真的，我真的觉得你会喜欢这个家伙的。他是我正在约会的一个女人的兄弟，我真的、真的希望你见见他。”我母亲可能凭直觉采用了“小损失”策略，同意和这个叫鲍勃的家伙见个面喝杯酒，对吧？不是去外地过周末，而是喝杯酒。结果，这个叫鲍勃的新家伙和玛丽一拍即合，非常喜欢对方，有许多共同点，他们最终结婚了，这就是我的父母。
Wow. And you can see how the intelligent failure in the first date, in some ways prompted your mom to do something very smart in the second date, which is to limit the size of the potential failure. So instead of spending a whole weekend with Bob, she met Bob for a drink. Can you talk about how this is also one of the markers of intelligent failure, which is you try to make the failure as small as you possibly can? It's so important that we minimize the waste.
哇。你可以看到第一次约会中的明智失败，在某种程度上促使你妈妈在第二次约会上做了一件非常聪明的事，那就是限制潜在失败的规模。因此，她没有和鲍勃共度整个周末，而是和鲍勃喝了杯酒。你能谈谈这如何也是明智失败的标志之一，也就是你尽量让失败的规模缩减到你所能做到的最小吗？尽量减少浪费是如此重要。
It's how much time, how many resources, how much of an investment do you have to make in an unknown outcome to get the information you need to then go forward? And of course, in a non-personal domain, you can see how organizations might be able to put this inside into practice. If you're training pilots, for example, maybe the smart thing is not to put them in a plane on day one, but to put them in a simulator. Exactly. Don't give them 200 living passengers who are depending on their skill to land the plane safely, put them in simulator. And in fact, you can give them all sorts of incredibly challenging scenarios and see
对于一个未知的结果，你必须投入多少时间、多少资源、多少投资，才能获得你继续前进所需的信息？当然，在一个非个人领域，你可以看到组织如何能够将这种洞察付诸实践。例如，如果你在培训飞行员，也许明智的做法不是第一天就把他们塞进飞机里，而是把他们放进模拟器中。完全正确。不要给他们200名依赖他们的技能安全降落飞机的活生生的乘客，把他们放进模拟器里。事实上，你可以给他们提供各种极其具有挑战性的场景，看看
how they do. Can you think of any other domains, Amy, where organizations can try and help people fail, but fail small rather than fail big? Well, in every organization, the research and development group is trying to develop new products and services that will in the future be the source of revenue. And you have experiments. You say, well, maybe this will work. Maybe they'll like this. Maybe this technology will work. And you're more often than not, you're mitigating the risk of customers thinking badly of you because you're having a failure, because you're having it in the R&D department, not out in the marketplace. A third marker of intelligent failure is that we have a very clear goal in mind.
他们的表现如何。埃米，你还能想到其他什么领域，组织可以尝试帮助人们失败，但是是小失败而不是大失败？嗯，在每个组织中，研发部门都在努力开发未来将成为收入来源的新产品和新服务。你会有实验。你会说：“嗯，也许这会行得通。也许他们会喜欢这个。也许这项技术会管用。”而且你更有可能在大多数情况下，减轻客户对你产生不好看法的风险，因为你经历了一次失败，因为你的失败是发生在研发部门，而不是在市场上。明智失败的第三个标志是，我们心中有一个非常清晰的目标。
And a vivid example of this comes from the inventor Thomas Edison. Tell me about his intelligent failure or rather his intelligent failures, Amy. Thomas Edison was dogged in his pursuit of the inventions that he knew or he believed were possible and he knew could really change lives. So he's of course credited with inventing the incandescent light bulb. And he tried literally thousands of different materials and techniques that one after another, they didn't work. They had all sorts of problems. But he didn't give up, he just kept going. And when a lab assistant, I think, attempting to be supportive,
而这方面的一个生动例子来自发明家托马斯·爱迪生。埃米，跟我讲讲他的明智失败，或者说他的那些明智失败。托马斯·爱迪生在追求他知道或认为可能、并知道真正能改变生活的小发明时，是极其执着的。因此，他当然被誉为发明了白炽灯泡。他确实尝试了成千上万种不同的材料和技术，一种接一种，它们都行不通。它们有各种各样的问题。但他没有放弃，他只是继续前进。当时一个实验室助手，我想，出于试图支持的心理，
said, gosh, all these failures must be very hard for you, sir. He responded, failures, I haven't failed. I've just found 10,000 ways that don't work. This is the very definition of intelligent failure here. Yeah, he completely understood the concept of intelligent failure. You have a goal, you've done your homework, you've used the knowledge you have from your prior experiences, from available literature, from you know, everything you can get your hands on, and then you reach that point where there is no way to go forward other than by trying it out, acting, having an experiment, and then
说：“天哪，先生，所有这些失败对你来说一定很难受吧。”他回答说：“失败？我没有失败。我只是找到了10000种行不通的方法。”这就是这里明智失败的定义。是的，他完全理解明智失败的概念。你有一个目标，你做了功课，你利用了你从先前的经验、从现有文献、从你知道的你能弄到的所有东西中获得的知识，然后你达到了那个点，除了尝试、行动、进行实验之外，没有其他前进的方式，然后
lo and behold, again, you were wrong. But fortunately, you're wrong behind closed doors or you're wrong at a small scale. You know, you haven't caused real harm. You haven't blown anything up. Another factor involved in Integent Failures is something you alluded to a second ago, Amy. And that is that we have done our homework. What does this turn mean?
不出所料，又一次，你错了。但幸运的是，你是在闭门造车时犯错，或者是在小范围内犯错。你知道，你没有造成真正的伤害。你没有炸毁任何东西。埃米，卷入明智失败的另一个因素是你刚才顺便提到的一点。那就是我们已经做好了功课。这个术语到底是什么意思？
Well, it means different things in different contexts. If you're a scientist hoping to make an important discovery and publish in a journal, it's about being up to date on the most recent research so that you're really in new territory. If you're going on a blind date with a friend of a friend, you have asked that friend, well, tell me about this person, right?
嗯，在不同的语境中，它意味着不同的事情。如果你是一位希望做出重要发现并在期刊上发表论文的科学家，这意味着要了解最新的研究动态，以便你确实处于新的领域。如果你和朋友的朋友去相亲，你已经问过那个朋友了，“嗯，跟我讲讲这个人吧，对吧？”
What do they like to do? You've found it as much as you can before agreeing to go spend time with them. You mentioned the work of the chemist, Jen, Hiemstra a little while ago. She and her team really did their homework when searching for a way forward to isolate nucleic acids. Can you explain what they were trying to do and what they did? Well, they were trying to get RNA, the double-stranded helix of RNA, to separate,
他们喜欢做什么？在同意花时间陪他们之前，你已经尽可能多地了解了情况。你刚才提到了化学家詹·海姆斯特拉的工作。她和她的团队在寻找分离核酸的方法时确实做好了功课。你能解释一下他们当时在尝试做什么以及他们做了什么吗？嗯，他们试图让RNA，即RNA的双链螺旋，分离开来，
and they tried various different reagents, which didn't work, and each of these experiments that fail is a disappointment. And yet, they doggedly continued. Then this young scientist named Steve Nudson in her lab went to the literature and found a rather obscure paper from the 1960s, and it was talking about a reagent called Léoxol. And because of the properties of Léoxol, Steve hypothesized that it might work in their goal to separate the strands of RNA and low and behold, it worked. So really, I think the picture I'm getting from UAE is that, you know, intelligent failures
他们尝试了各种不同的试剂，但都没有奏效，而每一次失败的实验都是一次失望。然而，他们顽强地坚持了下来。然后，她实验室里一位名叫史蒂夫·纳德森的年轻科学家查阅了文献，发现了一篇1960年代相当冷门的论文，里面提到了一种叫做“乐奥索尔”（Léoxol）的试剂。由于乐奥索尔的特性，史蒂夫假设它可能在他们分离RNA链的目标中发挥作用，结果不出所料，它成功了。所以，我从埃米这里得到的整体印象是，明智的失败
are not about gamblers or adventurers. In fact, they're taking chances while trying to de-risk things as much as possible. Yes, they want to succeed, but because they have chosen to try to succeed in new territory, can whether that scientific research or a blind date, they're willing to do the work. You mentioned something else a second ago as well, which I think is really germane here, which is that you need a really strong stomach to tolerate repeated failures because if you don't have that capacity, it's very difficult to practice intelligent failures. Yes, and you could think of that as a part of wisdom and a part of building
与赌徒或冒险家无关。事实上，他们在尝试尽可能降低风险的同时在冒险。是的，他们想要成功，但由于他们选择在新的领域尝试成功，无论是科学研究还是相亲，他们都愿意付出努力。你刚才还提到了另外一件事，我认为这在这里非常贴切，那就是你需要有一个真正强大的胃来忍受重复的失败，因为如果你没有这种能力，就很难去实践明智的失败。是的，你可以把它看作是智慧的一部分，也是建立
characters that ability to withstand the setbacks that are just ordinary parts of our jobs, their parts of our lives, and it's essential to appreciate how necessary they are, especially if you are trying to pursue great things. If you're trying to make a contribution, if you're trying to live a full life, you have to learn to reframe the setbacks as necessary as part of being human and not as bad. I don't like it too. Oh, that's disappointing, but it's okay. Yeah, I've discovered 5,999 ways that you cannot build a light bulb, that these are all discoveries, not failures.
品格的一部分，那种承受挫折的能力，而挫折只是我们工作的平常部分，它们是我们生活的一部分，并且至关重要的一点是要认识到它们是多么必要，特别是如果你正试图追求伟大的事情。如果你正试图做出贡献，如果你正试图过上充实的生活，你必须学会将挫折重新定义为成为人类的必要部分，而不是不好的事情。我也不喜欢它。哦，这令人失望，但没关系。是的，我已经发现了5999种无法制造电灯泡的方法，这些全部都是发现，而不是失败。
Yeah, I mean, if Edison was sincere, and I'm gonna believe that he was, he truly had learned how to think of each and every one of those failures as valuable information, as true discoveries in their own right. So that kind of cheerful attitude can seem polyanna-ish, but I disagree, right? I think it's actually scientifically valid.
是的，我的意思是，如果爱迪生是真诚的——而且我相信他是，他确实学会了如何将每一次失败都视为有价值的信息，视为它们本身真正的发现。所以这种乐观开朗的态度可能看起来有点过于盲目乐观，但我不同意，对吧？我认为它实际上在科学上是站得住脚的。
And perhaps a larger lesson is that many companies and many individuals should be seeking out intelligent failures more often. I think especially once you're an adult and once you have maybe some success or some area of expertise, it is so tempting to want to avoid failures at all costs, right, to not want to get anything wrong. So that would lead you to basically close yourself off from adventure, right, to not pick up a new sport or make new friends or pick up a hobby or shift careers in some way that might be meaningful, but scary to you. So, but then if you have a framework that says, well, it may not go well right away, but it will be an intelligent failure because, of course, I'm not supposed to be expert at that yet.
或许更宏大的教训是，许多公司和许多个人都应该更频繁地寻找明智的失败。我认为，特别是当你成为成年人之后，当你可能取得了一些成功或在某个专业领域有所建树时，不惜一切代价想要避免失败的诱惑是如此强烈，对吧，不想做错任何事。因此，这会引导你基本上将自己与冒险隔绝开来，对吧，不去学习一项新运动、不去结交新朋友、不去培养一种爱好，或者以某种对你来说可能很有意义但又很可怕的方式转换职业。所以，但是如果你有一个框架，它说，嗯，它可能不会立刻进展顺利，但它将是一次明智的失败，因为，当然，我还不是那方面的专家。
And the goal will be to learn. It helps you think, I think, a more productive and thoughtful way about new experiences so that you can welcome them rather than be reluctant to jump into them. Amy Edmondson teaches at the Harvard Business School. She's the author of Right Kind of Wrong, the Science of Failing Well. Amy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
目标将是去学习。我认为，这能帮助你以一种更具建设性和深思熟虑的方式看待新的经历，这样你就可以欢迎它们，而不是抗拒去尝试。埃米·埃德蒙森在哈佛商学院任教。她是《正确的失败：善于失败的科学》一书的作者。埃米，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget MacArthur, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Anson Kiro, we're bringing you a story from our sister show, My Anson Kiro. It comes from Susan Prescott. Her Anson Kiro is her 12th grade English teacher, Fred Demayo. One day, he assigned everyone a poem to recite in front
《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦克阿瑟、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。今天的“无名英雄”，我们为您带来一个来自我们姊妹节目《我的无名英雄》的故事。它来自苏珊·普雷斯科特。她的无名英雄是她12年级的英语老师弗雷德·德马约。一天，他布置每个人背诵一首诗，要在
of the class. And I was terrified. I had a mild stutter, and I thought there is no way I'm getting up there in front of my peers and speaking. So I went home, and I told my mother how I felt and she wrote me a note asking me to be excused from doing the assignment in front of the whole class. So the day of the public speaking assignment, I stayed after school. So I did instead of giving it in front of my peers. I gave it to him one-on-one after
全班面前背诵。我当时吓坏了。我有点轻微的口吃，我想我绝不可能站在同龄人面前说话。所以我回家了，我把我的感受告诉了我母亲，她写了一张便条，请求允许我免于在全班同学面前完成这项作业。所以在进行公众演讲作业的那天，我放学后留了下来。所以比起在同龄人面前进行演讲，我做了别的事。放学后，我
the school day. And we sat down and I recited my poem. And I don't remember if I started, but he looked at me when I was finished and he said, what was wrong with that? And I just sat there and he said, I liked listening to your voice. And I had never heard that before. I think in his mind, it was so minor and he wanted me to understand I have nothing to be afraid of. And I didn't realize how empowering that would be for me. And I
单独把诗背给他听。我们坐了下来，我背诵了我的诗。我不记得我是否结巴了，但当我背完时，他看着我说道：“这有什么不好的？”我只是坐在那里，他说：“我喜欢听你的声音。”我以前从未听到过这样的话。我想在他的脑海里，这微不足道，他希望我明白我没有什么好害怕的。我当时并没有意识到这对我来说会是多么具有赋能意义的事情，而我
never thanked him. I graduated and I just moved forward like a 18-year-old person will do. When I graduated from college, the second job I had was being a corporate trainer. So I stand up in front of people and I speak and I do it all the time. And if I do stutter once in a while, big whoop! And I'd like Mr. Dimeo to know that he truly is an unsung hero because he played a big role in my very successful career in my life.
从未向他道谢。我毕业了，然后就像一个18岁的年轻人会做的那样，径直向前迈进了。当我大学毕业时，我的第二份工作是做企业培训师。所以我站在人们面前讲话，我一直在这样做。如果我偶尔口吃一下，那算什么大不了的！我希望迪马约先生知道，他确实是一位无名英雄，因为他在我非常成功的事业和生活中发挥了巨大的作用。
And that was life-changing. I don't know where I would have gone if I felt like I had to keep my voice quiet because I was afraid of embarrassing myself. I'd like to give him my thanks for that kindness. Listen us Susan Prescott. You can hear many more stories like this on the Myung hero podcast or at hiddenbrain.org. If you liked today's episode, please share it with one or two people who you think would enjoy it.
那是改变人生的一幕。我不知道如果我觉得必须压抑自己的声音因为害怕出丑，我会走向何方。我要为那份善良向他表达我的感谢。听众朋友们，这是苏珊·普雷斯科特。您可以在《我的无名英雄》播客节目中或在 hiddenbrain.org 上听到更多类似的故事。如果您喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给一两位您认为会喜欢它的人。
Happy New Year from all of us at Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
隐藏的大脑团队祝大家新年快乐。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。回头见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。